alors c'est un groupe australien qui
fait un carton vous connaissiez bien sûr
bah c'est pas énorme et com com -
comment comment comment il a peur il
faut que sur libé comme comme à risque
de mec qui fait de la batterie par ali
permis de pousser feront ils sont beaux
gosses franchement bravo alors et thank
you ilike bois tu bois tu do alors c'est
le comble respect de leur nouvel album
qui arrive bientôt ils seront en concert
pour leurs fans parisiens demain soir
aux youyous aller les bras et aux
familles
non vraiment music you songs est
fabuleuse vu comme ils sont beaux noir
robe bialik comme vous êtes beau vous
êtes très beau beautiful beautiful
l'outil foule
dans ce but ils soient tous australiens
[Applaudissements]
parole c'est bon ça
assange les effraie
merci d'avoir un talent qu'on prenne un
peu de temps
[Applaudissements]